your child is sitting in a classroom right now
and somewhere in the world
a company just replaced an entire team of entry level workers
with artificial intelligence
these two facts are connected and most parents have no idea
here is something that should stop you in your tracks
The World Economic Forum says
artificial intelligence will reshape 22% of all jobs by 2030
that is not a distant future
that is before most children in school today
will even start their careers
and yet nearly half of all parents
have never had a single conversation with their child about it
not one let that sink in
we are living through the fastest technological shift in human history
artificial intelligence coding benchmarks
improved 16 fold in just 12 months
from 2023 to 2024
what took a decade in previous tech revolutions
is now happening in a single year
but here is what makes this moment truly urgent
a Samsung and Morning Consult survey
found that 88% of parents believe artificial intelligence knowledge
would be critical for their child's future
88%
that is nearly every parent in the room
but 81% of those same parents
do not believe artificial intelligence is even being taught
in their child's school
that gap between knowing something matters
and actually doing something about it
that is the gap that will define your child's future
parents are worried and they should be
but not for the reasons they think
65% of parents fear artificial intelligence will
destroy their child's ability to think critically
more than half fear it will make it harder for their kids to find jobs
forty four percent of parents across 19 countries say
they simply do not have the knowledge to guide
their children's artificial intelligence use
at all these are real fears
but fear without direction is just paralysis
and here is the uncomfortable truth about schools
Only 19% of schools have a formal artificial intelligence policy
68% of teachers received zero artificial intelligence training
this past school year zero
and yet 85% of those same teachers
were already using artificial intelligence tools in their classrooms
most of them without any guidance at all
the institutions we trust to prepare our children are themselves
unprepared so who is filling that gap right now
nobody and that is exactly why you are watching this
The World Economic Forum
projects that artificial intelligence will create 78 million
net new jobs
this decade 78 million
but only for people who are equipped with the right skills
the opportunity is enormous
but it will not wait countries like Finland Estonia
China and United Arab Emirates
are already teaching artificial intelligence literacy
from kindergarten
the UAE has made it a mandatory subject from age 4 through grade 12
China saw 80% of its students
report excitement about artificial intelligence
the United States 35% this is not just an education problem
it is a preparation problem and it starts at home
over the next seven episodes
we are going to give you everything you need
which jobs are disappearing
which ones are being created
what skills your child actually needs
what you can do tonight
what schools must change age by age
tools and activities and how to have this conversation with your child
without creating fear
because the families who understand what is coming
those are the families
who will turn this disruption into the greatest opportunity
of their children's lives
the artificial intelligence wake up call is ringing
this series is your answer